prostitution is not sin walk shoe stop
pits its thought between 200,000 and
400,000 women across Europe are forced
to work as prostitutes an increasing
number of them are Nigerian like the
woman we just heard they're lured to
Europe with false promises and end up in
backstreet brothels or red-light
districts and cities like Lyon Madrid or
here in terrine we joined volunteers
from a Catholic charity who try to get
the girls off the street 9 Nigerian
women currently live in this house in
Italy we can't use their real names as
recognized victims of sexual abuse they
won't be deported at least for now Kate
arrived in Europe a year ago they told
me they were going to find a job for me
that there's a lot of job here but it
inter meets it's on the streets job is
on the streets for many women their
troubles begin on their way to Europe I
was raped twice when I was in Nigeria
the person that they Bogart me to
Cardinal under that time was when I was
in the days at the soldiers they also
did to see networks of people smugglers
traffic the women the networks are
headed by so-called Madame's women who
enslave other women having been promised
a great life the women are abused by
their captors when they arrive until
they give in the charity were observing
is using an online campaign to try to
raise awareness about the plight of the
women Katia is one of the volunteers is
very common when they gasp tell us that
groups of men go to them to rate them
together one two three at the same
moment they ask them to do many strange
things
to pay them like nothing like a Nigeria
whom are on the road is paid 10 arrow
you don't buy pizza with coca-cola for
ten hour some women have sex with up to
20 men a night they have to pay off
their huge debts these can total as much
as forty thousand euros for the journey
as well as for food clothes or cosmetics
but if they go to the police
the women risk deportation that would
shatter their dream of finding a much
better life in Europe in the end they no
longer know whom to trust
sometimes even the woman's own families
turn against them it used to happen many
times that the families suggest to the
girls to go back to prostitution in that
case we understand that they have been
sold from their horn families
katia and many other volunteers here
believe the women can still have a
better future she helps them get their
papers and report the abusers to police
the women are still terrified of
breaking their silence but they also
want to see the traffickers arrested and
ultimately spare other women from a
similar fate